[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by megan good aka
camille and jerry johnson aka tai in
harlem which the full season comes out
on prime video on friday i'm so excited
to see you guys how you doing today
i'm good how are you
good so my first question is for megan
megan there's a particular scene early
in the season i absolutely love where
camille is practicing saying something
to somebody in the mirror and she's
trying on all these different outfits
i have to know in some of these great
comedic scenes that i laugh really hard
at is there a lot of improvising going
on are you sticking straight to a script
here
um both you know tracy oliver is
incredible you know so so much of it is
on the page and then they just let us
play you know and and the wonderful
thing is like we've gotten to know these
characters so well
that it just happens like like
the the line where um you know uh uh
quinn says uh something about being a
hoe and i'm like i ain't been a host
since 2005. like that kind of stuff is
like improvised but there's it there's a
lot of freedom and there's a lot already
on the page and so it's kind of like a
wonderful
marriage in that sense
yeah and it's great because all your
performances i love seeing because you
blend so well comedy and doing drama as
well so it's really shown here which is
awesome um
jerry i love that to me tai is the voice
of reason in the show and as a truth
speaker
i'll say that
i'll say it again no but
do you find a lot of tai in
jerry
yes
yes and no okay because i don't want
these women to think i'm a hoe because
i'm not
she's not a hug
some people might say don't be talking
about thailand
but i think that there is tai
really allowed me to explore another
part of myself because i feel like for a
long time like the people who know me
know the thai in me
but
like i could get glitzy and glamorous
and then people make assumptions about
who i am based off that but i'm a [ __ ]
at her okay okay
and so i feel like um
not only that aspect but also
thai being so driven
i am a virgo moon and a virgo rising i
am an aquarius but i am a virgo born in
the virgo rising and i can once i see
something i have to see it through it's
like whatever i don't care about i'm
going to see it through and tai is very
determined in that way and it did come
from like me not having much growing up
and so and i think it's it's similar to
tai of like
i
th there's no way that i can lose
because i can never go back to there and
reality is right you'll never be back
right and and at some point you have to
slow down or stop and and and figure out
how things need to shift but that's the
thing that's always being chased like i
need to make this better for
generational whatever or with my lineage
to come and so i think uh ty's
determination and her swagginess
definitely resonates she is a person
that lives inside of me yes
that's awesome and yeah it's going to
resonate with the audience it's it's
such an interesting character to watch
too and you do such a good job at it um
megan were you always going to play the
role of camille and just in general with
this cast with you four leads was it
always going to be everyone playing when
they are
that kind of change at points
it i was always going to be who everyone
is playing but um but i resonated with
every single one of the characters and
you know as i said earlier like i see
myself in every single one of the
characters and i think every one of the
characters would be fun to play
um but
for me with camille
there's a part of me that as an actress
i really haven't got a chance to like
tap in into and show which is like the
physical comedy and the quirkiness and
the weirdness and
all the offbeatness that actually is
megan um and so it's been fun to to play
this character and to kind of have that
freedom to just
just see whatever comes out you know and
with what the magic can be and so um but
yeah we from the moment we all you know
because jerry and um grace got cast at
first and me and shaniqua tested
together with them um and so yeah from
day one it was
and i'm so happy i want to say i want to
give a little nod to megan right now i'm
so happy because i am a megan fan
um to see to be able to play with her
but to see how well she plays in the
freedom of this character and the
freedom of this script it's like
[ __ ] you are brilliant
i'm really happy that she gets to play
camille
yeah and what people are gonna be
excited to see in this interview is how
close you guys are and you've shared
that on social media it's amazing and it
really shines through in the show so
everybody watch megan and jerry kill it
this friday all ten episodes of harlem
restaurants it's only five dollars at
all that's right you get the whole thing
yes uh thank you guys so much for
joining me and i hope to talk to you in
the future one day thank you